the game spots continuing coverage of e3
2014 i feel like i've been here since
the dawn of time but sadly the show must
end soon but not before we got a bunch
of great games on battlecry ea sports
ufc hell a bunch of games but right now
we got john ribbons from row seven my
friend hey man good to see you good to
see somebody from london i miss it i was
there for four years i miss it i've only
been gone two days in fact the last time
i met you was at pax east
you're showing off not a hero you guys
have made ali ali before when i saw it
there it was right beside the hotline
booth and it seemed like a load of
people were
watching your game we're like this looks
really interesting it was one of those
like i hope they do well and then lo and
behold playstation 4 in vida yes it's
it's worked out pretty good did you guys
has that been part of the plan for a
while did you guys know you're going to
be on playstation or well it's been
interesting because obviously we did uh
ollie ollie with sony and ended up doing
not a hero with devolver and i think
they were talking okay and we were
talking so it's nice that it's kind of
all come together and
all the people that we've been working
with have been helping us out or
actually now we're collaborating at the
same time yeah well okay a lot of people
probably know about ali ali so we're
watching and not a hero right now so
explain for the folks at home the sort
of nuts and bolts of our what we're
playing here okay so uh not a hero is a
2d cover-based shoot-em-up um so
basically it's all about sliding taking
cover shooting and like managing your
ammunition uh it's called not a hero
because like you're basically not that
much more powerful than the guys you're
fighting against so you've got to like
you've got to be really strategic and
you'll be really careful because you die
super fast you can pick your character
here i see jesus is there there's jesus
clive
is that the jesus that's it's kind of a
big lebowski reference yeah pink spandex
uh cletus it's pretty good he's a
hillbilly with a shotgun oh we're going
to see a bit of him now so they all kind
of play with that mechanic of like slide
and uh slide and shoot and reload uh so
cletus has got a shotgun he can like
shoot doors off hinges send doors flying
into people and like knock them over and
then run in and execute them and stuff
like that all right so you're trying to
get to the top of the building i'm
guessing how how's this cover so
the objectives like vary in each mission
uh so sometimes you're like collecting
stuff sometimes you've got to
assassinate people sometimes you just
don't wipe out everyone in the whole
building um
and it kind of varies up sometimes
you're coming in from the bottom you're
trying to get to the roof and get to a
helicopter other missions you're
actually starting in the building and
it's being like raided by swat teams or
raided by assassins and you kind of got
like a horde mode thing where you're
fighting people
how many times can you get hit before
you get you before you're done
so there's like tiny little dots
underneath uh underneath the player you
can get here four times but basically
like if they've got a machine gun they
hit you you're pretty much dead like you
got to use cover all the time so you're
are you popping into cover automatically
and then when you hit fire he's like
jumping out and doing it yeah so you've
got this like z you hit z and you slide
and if you touch anything you can hide
behind when you're sliding you'll just
take cover and hide straight away
there's almost like a sort of a rhythm
to it where you're trying to just
basically be out of step with when
they're shooting yeah so like i guess
there's always a very different game to
ali early but like ali ali had that
rhythm of like
uh trick grind land trick land trick
land that whole like rhythm you've got
between the buttons it's quite similar
with not a hero you've got this like
slide cover pop shoot slide cover pop
reload that kind of thing uh were you
working on the two of them uh
concurrently because
they're you know both in terms of how it
looks and in terms of the the general
feel it's almost like you learned a lot
while making ali ali that probably went
into this well yeah it's interesting
like we started um made
prototype for all early back in 2012
and then we sort of signed up with sony
um we had like a chance meeting got a
chance meeting with them we were
introduced by another studio
they signed all the ollie and then it
took us like six months of like you know
contracts and back and forth with sony
to sort out doing that so now six months
was like couldn't work on all the early
like what we're gonna do oh really so
like oh we're just building another
prototype so we started making this
dungeon crawling game called jeffrey
archer which was awful
and then we put a guy with a gun in it
yeah yeah okay you might get this
[ __ ] title
um
so we started like we made that it was
awful we added guns and then it
basically became not a hero so we'd
worked on it for like four months then
we jumped on alioli for a year so we
didn't even look at this oh wow okay for
like a whole year and then we came back
to it so it was good coming back to it
having finished like our first really
big game
you know and having to do like awards
and achievements all that kind of stuff
that you wouldn't like you don't really
think about when you're doing a
prototype so it's nice coming back to
not a hero off the back of alioli and
being like okay we've had some
experience of doing that like
that sort of top layer like meta gaming
it's in your site now you understand
that it's going to be there
so what's the sort of onus then on each
on the levels is is there a story
happening are you doing repeating levels
to like i bet there's a story happening
i bet it's really bloody dumb
it's okay so you
the game didn't have a story and we kind
of needed to come up with something
inside altogether okay so we decided it
should just be ridiculous so basically
um
you work for a time-traveling purple
rabbit called bunny lord
he's come back in time to become mayor
of the town and he's doing that by
wiping out all the mob bosses and
gangsters and general bad guys well he's
not doing that he's hired this team of
like basic you know part-time murderers
to go around doing it for him unemployed
people yes unemployed murderers
basically um but in each level you've
got like you can see there's like four
objectives in the bottom of the screen
so you've got like the top one is your
core objective yeah so if you beat that
like plant the bomb on escape is all you
have to do to finish the mission
and the other three are optional
um but they kind of stack so like you
get a four-star rating based on how many
of them you beat
if you beat like two of them you get two
stars and so on but they stack up so you
have the only way to get a four-star is
to beat all four all three optional
objectives in one run so like you might
get one that's like fire 60 shots that's
quite easy to do you might get another
one that says only reload on your gum
gun is empty okay that's quite easy to
do but to do them both at the same time
in one run is actually like really hard
i like that maybe it doesn't come across
when you're watching it um perhaps it
does but i remember when i played
there i was times where i was in the
shadows i needed i popped out to take a
shot and the gun just went click click
and then i was like no goddamn and then
they will just rush you basically you
forget about um having to reload can you
can you rush them when they don't have
yeah yeah you can rush and slide them
and then execute them on the floor um
well actually it depends which character
you're playing us but yeah most of them
have got like an execute as well well
they're like tom of the moment's playing
is uh jesus he's definitely going to get
killed a lot
but like he's just got the he's got this
gun that just fires bullets so fast as
soon as you unlock him you start running
around you're like i'm invincible and
everyone like gets two kills runs out of
ammo just runs into the next room with
like an empty gun and they already just
jump out straight away yeah yeah is
there other um
other weapons you can pick up like i
said i think i've seen mines and stuff
so you get like two types of power up um
when you kill enemies at close range
they drop ammo power ups okay so they
like change the kind of bullets so like
right now uh tom's got like armor
piercing they'll just fly through
everything so you can like kill the
lines of your eyes you can shoot them in
cover and anything you want
uh you get like ricochet which bounce
around rooms you get one that turns all
your bullets into like shotgun shells
you blow people through doors and stuff
and then you get stuff like this like
the nuclear cat so this is like a cat
you can unleash that then like just
blows up entire floors i'll do it um
land mines uh pipe bombs nail bombs
sweet all kinds of stuff there's gonna
be a lot more weaponised animals in the
final version as well everyone seems to
love the cat it's what the community
wants yes
people get the cat and they're really
happy so we're thinking like homing
pigeons and a mole that digs through the
floor and then blows up on the floor
below
basically any animal it could be a
weapon i think is a way forward if you
have any suggestions by all means uh
stick them in the chat at daniel dwyer
or send it to me on twitter as well
and if you have any questions to that
effect as well uh the uk games um
industry is not that big uh what was it
like when you guys saw at gunpoint
getting released
i was actually on the alpha of gunpowder
yeah so i played that um ages and ages
and ages ago before it would come out um
that's one of my favorite games that
punch sound when you knock people over
you can just hit them in the face
it's so satisfying
what's it like you guys are operating in
london right yes and there's not there's
a couple of studios there there's like i
know honey slogger down there and
there's hey there's uh i don't know now
i'm gonna sound like i should be able to
name a bunch of studios but i can't um
yeah there's not like a huge number of
like big studios but there's like a
really good indie scene in london um
there's a couple of meet-up groups for
like indie developers and stuff like
that um
like one of them london indies is
getting like 100 120 people coming down
oh really uh on like first monday of
every month how long how long has role 7
been together uh since 2008 oh wow
that's actually going on but we
when we founded it we decided we were
going to be like a marketing agency okay
and that we'd use the profit from that
to make games wow uh but we then learned
that that doesn't really work and you
end up just doing marketing stuff and
not getting to make your own games at
all uh so it was only really in 20 in
2012 we did our first
like we made games for other people yeah
yeah but in 2012 was the first time we
did like your own game which was ali ali
again no it just gets to the exit which
is nice
you've never heard of it because it
totally flops
you guys seem to be coming good i've
already got some nice global recognition
and it seems to be a lot of buzzwords
not a hero as well so we're looking at
this stage how grand is i hate these
super reductive questions but how grand
is it in terms of like variety of levels
replayability and stuff like that um so
you've kind of got
there's going to be four districts in
the city so you play through um
that uh challenge system where you've
got one primary and three optional ones
so if you beat the district just beating
the primary objectives at the end of
that district you unlock a new character
cool um you can then go back and if you
can perfect every level so like
four-star every single level in that
district you unlock another character
um but some of those challenges are set
up so that you kind of need to go play
through a bunch of levels unlock a new
guy who's got a specific skill and then
come back to an earlier level and it's
much easier to beat it with that guy so
like jesus that oh he's playing as steve
right now um but like steve ain't no
massage steve didn't die for anyone's
sins
steve's like the first guy you get he's
like he's actually super rubbish but
he's still my favorite character
actually in this level you get like a
buddy so you're actually running around
with bunny lord like your employer
and this thing's reading the paper well
we had like a bug we couldn't get the ai
to work properly and actually make him
follow you but it was super i hate games
but like the ai is just annoying like
guys get lost so instead of just having
him bug out we just make him read a
newspaper until you go back and find him
that's pretty good go and get him tom
you should leave that
come on bunny
there you go much better
you guys are making some really
interesting games that are they're
almost i hate the term but like like the
snackable i heard somebody say yesterday
like once you can kind of sit there like
ali ali was very much a i'm gonna pick
this up and play it for about five ten
minutes yes great sit down and then like
next day
5 10 minutes again like this seems very
similar
is that a bet is that a like a reason in
relation to the size of your team the
way you like to design games i think i
think it's something that happened
inadvertently i don't think we kind of
set out to go we'll make games you can
play while you're having a poo yeah um
and then you'll end up sat there for
like three hours yeah until right but um
but i think that's kind of what we've
ended up doing like i really enjoy games
where like
there's like a high level of challenge
but you don't feel so bad about dying
because you're like straight back in and
you can just keep going um
so yeah i think this has become our
thing we didn't mean it to happen but
it's happened apparently
excellent uh so this is coming out on
playstation 4 and playstation vita
playstation 4 playstation beta and then
pc mac linux oh as well yes will it be
days both playstation and pc it's going
to be i think it's going to be steam
slightly before and then it'll be uh ps4
and beta after that
you guys haven't gotten any early access
or stuff like that going on it's just
early 2015 so january february time okay
all right you're going to take your time
i like it yeah all right absolute
pleasure my friends are having something
i'm not a hero from row seven uh john
gibb john ribbons yes ribbons i
basically got john gibbons john gibbons
john ribbons ribbons all kinds of things
have you had a bunch of interviews since
you got this is your first d3 right this
is my first d3 yeah have you enjoyed it
yeah it's been awesome have you got to
see much no i haven't seen anything
you're interviewing people like me
saying
yes mainly but it's fine that's all good
i'm just happy people want to see it
well congratulations on getting signed
up with tony it's awesome when i saw you
guys at pax east it was a it was a
really you know it's good to see
fun games getting picked up by large
console manufacturers and see you guys
on stage as well is really awesome so
congratulations enjoy the rest of year
three stay right here